north stream 2 es el nombre del
gasoducto que genera discordia entre
alemania y ucrania y fue uno de los
principales puntos en el encuentro entre
la canciller angela merkel y el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
visiblemente preocupado por una eventual
amenaza de rusia
miramos a este proyecto solo desde la
perspectiva de la seguridad
y lo consideramos una arma geopolítica
peligrosa del kremlin
en el gasoducto pasa por el fondo del
mar báltico y conecta directamente rusia
con alemania el problema para ucrania es
que este nuevo proyecto la privaría de
miles de millones de dólares en
lucrativas tarifas pues el país es
actualmente tierra de tránsito para
gasoductos rusos alemania dijo que
buscará que se extienda el acuerdo de
tránsito existente con ucrania que
expira en 2024 y advirtió de sanciones
en caso de agresión
hemos dejado claro que buscaremos más
sanciones dentro del marco europeo si se
confirma la sospecha de que el gasoducto
se utiliza como arma geopolítica por
parte de rusia y hemos dejado claro que
iniciaremos negociaciones sobre la
posibilidad de extender el contrato a
partir de 2024 para que ucrania pueda
tener seguridad en este nivel la líder
alemana ha sido un aliado clave de quiet
desde 2014 cuando moscú anexo la
península de crimea pero el
controvertido gasoducto enfrío la
relación entre los dos países el
proyecto de unos 12.000 millones de
dólares está a punto de ser terminado
justo en momentos en los que ucrania se
prepara para celebrar el aniversario 30
de su independencia de la unión
soviética